This is how far it's gone. In his office at a place called The Innocence Project in New York, Huy Dao stands amidst piles of letters and legal documents.
事情已经发展到了这种地步。在纽约一家名为“清白计划”（The Innocence Project）的办公室里，休·道（Huy Dao）站在成堆的信件和法律文件中间。
I'm not really sure how to describe it. At some points, the piles are actually as tall as I am and I'm six feet tall. It might be funny if it weren't so sobering at the same time.
我真不知道该怎么形容。有时候，这些文件堆得和我一样高，而我有一米八三高。如果不是因为这事儿同时让人感到如此沉重，或许还会显得有些滑稽。
Just outside the door of his office are four stacks of letters that go waist high.
就在他办公室门外，堆放着四叠齐腰高的信件。
We estimate there's 2,000 letters here that have only been logged in and not even looked at. The volume of mail has grown exponentially. If you had come here two years ago, there would have been two weeks worth of mail and now there's eleven months worth.
我们估计这里有2000封信，仅仅是登记在册，甚至还没人看上一眼。信件的数量呈指数级增长。如果你两年前来这里，当时可能只有两周的信，而现在却是十一个月的量。
All these letters from prisoners who hope that DNA evidence will set them free. These are the only cases The Innocence Project takes on. For after they're done screening the letters and choosing the best cases and sending the prisoners to get their DNA tested, half the time, the test proves the prisoner was guilty, which when you think about it, the prisoner knew all along.
所有这些信都来自那些寄希望于DNA证据能让他们重获自由的囚犯。这些是“清白计划”受理的唯一案件类型。因为在他们筛选完信件、选出最有把握的案件并让囚犯接受DNA测试后，有一半的情况测试结果显示囚犯确实有罪——当你仔细想想，囚犯其实从一开始就知道这一点。
How far has it gone? How much have things changed because of DNA evidence? The largest and oldest private DNA forensics lab in the country, Cellmark Diagnostics in Germantown, Maryland, still tests for murder and sexual assault cases. But now the fastest-growing part of their business is old, unsolved cases. They test evidence for over 500 of these a month. Lab director Charlotte Word says they're also doing robberies, assaults, criminal paternity suits, private eye work, insurance fraud, medical malpractice--
事情发展到什么地步了？由于DNA证据，情况发生了多大的变化？全美规模最大、历史最悠久的私营DNA法医实验室——位于马里兰州日耳曼敦的Cellmark Diagnostics公司，依然在为谋杀案和性侵案进行检测。但现在，他们业务中增长最快的部分是那些陈年的悬案。他们每月要处理超过500起这类案件的证据。实验室主任夏洛特·沃德（Charlotte Word）说，他们现在还承接抢劫、伤害、刑事亲子鉴定、私家侦探委托、保险欺诈、医疗事故调查等业务。
Well, there have been cases where individuals were told they had cancer. They went in and had an organ or tissue or something removed, and then when the pathologist did the review of those tissue samples, no form of cancer was identified. So the question was, in the original slide that was looked at, was there a mistake that this slide really belongs to someone else who truly has cancer?
嗯，有些病例是患者被告知患有癌症。他们去做了器官或组织摘除手术，但当病理学家复核这些组织样本时，却发现并没有任何癌症迹象。所以问题是，在最初检查的载玻片中，是不是出了差错，其实这片载玻片属于另一个真正患有癌症的人？
A person who actually has cancer but doesn't know it because the slides got switched?
一个真正患有癌症却因为载玻片被调包而不知情的人？
That's correct.
没错。
How far has it gone? Even medium-sized cities like Arlington, Texas, population 350,000, are going back through all their old, unsolved homicides to see if there's evidence with usable DNA.
事情发展到什么地步了？即使是像德克萨斯州阿灵顿这样人口35万的中型城市，也在重新审查所有陈年的未结凶杀案，看看是否留有可用的DNA证据。
I found it very interesting to go through some of these large case books or three-ring binders full of yellowed investigative notes from decades gone by.
我觉得翻看这些巨大的卷宗或装满了几十年前泛黄调查笔记的三孔活页夹，非常有趣。
Detective John Stanton says that one case he stumbled upon was one that he had worked on himself on his first day on the job as a crime scene officer on Valentine's Day, 1985: the grisly murder of a young woman.
侦探约翰·斯坦顿（John Stanton）说，他偶然发现的一个案子，正是他在1985年情人节第一天上班时作为犯罪现场警察参与调查的案件：那是一起针对一名年轻女性的残忍谋杀案。
Back then, we had a cigarette butt in that case, believe it or not. And, of course, back then, just how definitive a piece of evidence this is going to be, it's probably not. There's probably a lot of people who smoke this brand of cigarette.
当时，信不信由你，我们在那起案件中发现了一个烟头。当然，在那个年代，这是否能成为决定性的证据还很难说。毕竟抽这种烟的人可能有很多。
Nearly 20 years later, he opened the evidence bag that he'd sealed back in 1985. And the DNA in the saliva on the cigarette butt was perfectly preserved. Matching it with a DNA profile in a database is probably the only hope of ever solving this murder. There are over 1,266,000 DNA profiles of criminals in government databases. But that number is climbing fast as more states gear up their programs. 1,300 criminals are matched to crimes every year by the FBI through their DNA.
近20年后，他打开了自己在1985年密封的证据袋。烟头上唾液里的DNA保存得非常完好。将它与数据库中的DNA档案进行比对，恐怕是解决这起谋杀案的唯一希望。目前政府数据库中存有超过126.6万份罪犯的DNA档案。但随着越来越多的州启动他们的项目，这个数字正在迅速攀升。联邦调查局（FBI）每年通过DNA比对破获1300起犯罪案件。
So that case may rest very strongly on that little cigarette butt.
所以，这起案件的胜负可能很大程度上取决于那个小小的烟头。
How far has it gone? Here in Illinois, there have been more wrongful convictions overturned with DNA evidence than anywhere in the country. 18. Enough people wrongly sentenced to death that a Republican governor put a moratorium on the death penalty and commuted the sentences of everyone on death row in the state, 167 people.
事情发展到什么地步了？在伊利诺伊州，通过DNA证据平反的冤假错案数量居全国之首，达到了18起。由于被错误判处死刑的人数太多，一位共和党州长下令暂停执行死刑，并将该州死刑犯名单上的167人的减刑。
Maurice Possley has written a number of investigative stories about wrongful convictions for the Chicago Tribune, and he says that one of the most important things about DNA evidence is that by overturning these convictions, it's giving us a window into some disturbing police procedures. How they get innocent people to confess to crimes they did not commit, how they get witnesses to lie, and pin crimes on innocent people.
莫里斯·波斯利（Maurice Possley）为《芝加哥论坛报》撰写了许多关于冤假错案的调查报道。他说，DNA证据最重要的一点在于，通过推翻这些定罪，它为我们揭开了一些令人不安的警察办案流程。比如他们如何诱使无辜者承认他们并未犯下的罪行，以及如何诱导证人撒谎，将罪名强加给清白的人。
People said these things happened before. These are not new accusations. But now people can make those with a new certainty. This is not guesswork in these cases.
人们以前就说过这些事发生过。这些并非新的指控。但现在，人们可以用一种新的确定性来提出这些指控。在这些案件中，这不再是猜测。
The newest thing that's happening, he says, is that even in cases where there's no DNA evidence, prosecutors and judges are willing to go back and consider whether there might have been a wrongful conviction.
他说，最新出现的情况是，即使在没有DNA证据的案件中，检察官和法官也愿意回过头来重新审视是否可能存在冤假错案。
Because DNA has showed us that mistakes can be made and are made, they are willing to take a look at those cases. That's significant because heretofore, you really needed incredibly powerful evidence to even get in the courthouse door.
因为DNA已经向我们证明，错误是可能发生且确实发生了的，所以他们愿意重新审视那些案件。这意义重大，因为在此之前，你真的需要极其强有力的证据才能迈进法院大门。
This is just how far it's gone. This is the historic change that's been wrought with DNA evidence. Never before have we had evidence that is so good, so indisputable, that it doesn't just prove wrongdoing by criminals, it sometimes proves wrongdoing by police and prosecutors. Today on our radio show we look at what it has revealed to us as it's done that.
这就是事情发展的程度。这是DNA证据所带来的历史性变革。我们从未有过如此出色、如此不容置疑的证据，它不仅证明了罪犯的罪行，有时还证明了警察和检察官的不法行为。今天在我们的广播节目中，我们将探讨它在完成这些工作时向我们揭示了什么。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in two acts. In Act Two, in the second half of our show, we will look at how police interrogation procedures-- common procedures, no violence, nothing fancy-- were able to get a normal, suburban, 14-year-old boy to confess to killing his own sister, a crime it was proven later he did not do.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《这就是美国生活》（This American Life），由公共广播国际公司分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我们今天的节目分为两部分。在第二幕，也就是节目的后半部分，我们将看看警察的审讯程序——那些常见的、没有暴力、没有什么花招的程序——是如何让一个正常的14岁郊区男孩承认杀害了自己的亲妹妹，而事实证明他并没有犯罪。
And we begin our show with Act One, an act that we are calling Rabbits and Hawks. This is a story about some teenagers who were wrongfully convicted of murder and who served 15 years before DNA evidence got them out. One of the things that's extraordinary about this story is that there is no ambiguity at all at this point about their innocence. We don't have to wonder about any little loopholes. Not only did DNA evidence prove that they had not done the crime, two other guys confessed to the crime 15 years after the fact and their DNA evidence was a perfect match. Shane DuBow about tells this story and explains how police pinned the crime on these first guys.
节目开头是第一幕，我们称之为“兔子与鹰”。这是一个关于几名青少年被错误地指控谋杀并入狱15年，最终靠DNA证据重获自由的故事。这个故事最非凡之处在于，这一点上他们的清白毫无歧义。我们不需要去琢磨任何法律漏洞。不仅DNA证据证明了他们没有犯罪，而且15年后，另外两名男子承认了罪行，他们的DNA与现场证据完全吻合。肖恩·杜博（Shane DuBow）讲述了这个故事，并解释了警察是如何将罪名强加给这几名受害者的。
This is the story of how one tragedy became two. The first involves a young woman named Lori Roscetti who was raped and killed in 1986. The second involves four innocent teenagers who were wrongfully imprisoned for that crime. In Chicago that year, 284 other murders took place. But Lori's was the one that grabbed the top headlines and came to be viewed as a symbol as much as anything else. A typical quote from the papers read, "It wasn't just a murder. It was a bestial, barbaric, horrifying, senseless massacre."
这是一个关于一桩悲剧如何演变成两桩悲剧的故事。第一桩涉及一名叫洛里·罗斯切蒂（Lori Roscetti）的年轻女性，她在1986年被强奸并杀害。第二桩涉及四名被错误囚禁的无辜青少年。那一年在芝加哥，发生了284起其他谋杀案。但洛里的案件成了占据头条新闻的那个，并被视为一种象征。报纸上的一段典型引文写道：“这不仅仅是一起谋杀。这是一场兽性、野蛮、恐怖、毫无意义的大屠杀。”
She was a medical student, bright, promising. Of course the fact that she was also white medical student murdered in a black neighborhood was a constant subtext. Her body was found by some railroad tracks, not far from her car. Her head had been bashed in with a rock. When no arrest came quickly, people got upset. A reward was offered. There was a march on a police station. Some students held a vigil. The pressure was on and the police needed suspects. On January 24, three months after the murder, they dragged in 16-year-old Larry Ollins.
她是一名医学生，聪明、有前途。当然，她是死在一个黑人社区的白人医学生这一事实，一直是一个潜台词。她的尸体是在离她车子不远处的铁轨旁发现的。她的头被石头砸碎了。当警方没有迅速逮捕嫌疑人时，人们感到愤怒。悬赏金被提出来了。人们在警察局前游行。一些学生举行了守夜活动。压力很大，警察需要嫌疑人。1月24日，在谋杀案发生三个月后，他们抓住了16岁的拉里·奥林斯（Larry Ollins）。
A little about Larry. He's got an angular build, a slow smile, and a habit of squinting that can make him seem moody even when he's not. Back then, he'd already been arrested several times for things like non-violent burglaries. The police, he says, strapped him to a wall, slapped him around, and then started asking him leading questions about a vague but brutal crime. They wanted him to admit to it. Instead, he told them this.
说说拉里。他体型瘦长，笑容迟缓，还有个喜欢眯着眼睛的习惯，这让他看起来即使在心情不错时也显得有些忧郁。在那之前，他曾因非暴力的入室盗窃等罪名多次被捕。他说，警察把他绑在墙上，扇他耳光，然后开始问他一些关于模糊但残忍的罪行的诱导性问题。他们想要他承认。相反，他告诉他们这些。
I don't know nothing. I can't tell you nothing because I don't know nothing. I know a little bit about the law because I have been arrested before, man. I'm not taking no murder case or no rape and all this other stuff. I'll take one of them missing candy bar cases you all got missing in the back, but I ain't going to be able to do this, man.
我什么都不知道。我什么也告诉不了你们，因为我什么都不知道。我懂一点法律，因为我以前被捕过，伙计。我不会承担什么谋杀或强奸案，还有其他这些破事。你们要是缺什么偷糖果的案子，我倒是可以认一个，但我真干不了这个，伙计。
The police were unable to bully a confession from Larry, but their tactics worked better on his friend, Marcellius Bradford and his 14-year-old cousin, Calvin. Marcellius says the police beat him up until he gave in. Calvin says he was tricked. After keeping him for hours, Calvin says, the police told him that if he'd just sign a confession, he could go home and see his mom. He signed. They locked him up instead. And because both confessions also named Larry, the police locked him up too, in solitary confinement, without even fully explaining his charges.
警察没能从拉里身上通过恐吓得到供词，但他们的策略在他朋友马塞勒斯·布拉德福德（Marcellius Bradford）和14岁的表弟卡尔文（Calvin）身上起到了更好的效果。马塞勒斯说，警察对他进行了殴打，直到他屈服。卡尔文说他是被骗了。在扣留他几个小时后，卡尔文说，警察告诉他，如果他签署一份认罪书，他就能回家见到妈妈。他签了。结果他们却把他关了起来。因为两份供词都提到了拉里，警察也把拉里关了起来，单独监禁，甚至没有完全向他说明指控内容。
I'm sitting in that room. I can't come out. I'm in there 24 hours a day for about a week. I was just so depressed, man, from not understanding how it was that they pulled this stuff off that I couldn't even eat. I couldn't even drink. And I wasn't using the washroom that much. All this stuff just happened instantly. And when they detained me and put me in this room, I could hear the TV out there. I could hear the TV, and it would get real quiet because the TV is talking about me.
我坐在那个房间里。我出不去。我一天24小时被关在里面，大约待了一周。我当时太沮丧了，伙计，因为我不明白他们到底是怎么策划这一切的，我甚至吃不下饭。我连水都喝不下。厕所也很少用。所有这些事情瞬间就发生了。当他们拘留我并把我关在那个房间里时，我能听到外面的电视声。我能听到电视声，而且会变得非常安静，因为电视里正在谈论我。
Well, two of three teenagers being held in the rape and murder of medical student Lori Roscetti are being held without bond tonight. 17-year-old Marcellius Bradford, shown here in the yellow hat, appeared in court today along with 16-year-old Larry Ollins, who is being tried as an adult.
好的，三名被拘留的涉及医学生洛里·罗斯切蒂强奸谋杀案的青少年中有两人今晚被不予保释。17岁的马塞勒斯·布拉德福德（戴黄帽子者）今天出庭，16岁的拉里·奥林斯也将作为成年人受审。
And I could hear through my doors because it's got big cracks through the doors. And it's talking about the Roscetti case and this and that. So I put my ear to the door and I'm starting to hear the story.
我能透过门听到声音，因为门上有很大的缝隙。他们在谈论罗斯切蒂案，这个那个的。所以我把耳朵贴在门上，开始听这个故事。
With one of the youths driving, Roscetti was taken a mile south to this isolated stretch of railroad tracks.
其中一名青年开车，罗斯切蒂被带到一英里外那段孤立的铁轨上。
Once at the location, one of the offenders took Miss Roscetti out of the vehicle to the rear of the auto and brutally violated her. An argument ensued between the first offender and the others over who would assault the lady next.
到达现场后，其中一名罪犯把罗斯切蒂小姐从车里拉出来带到车后，残忍地侵犯了她。第一名罪犯和其他人之间为了谁下一个轮到强奸而发生了争吵。
This is a particularly gruesome crime and the ages involved of the people that perpetrated it is absolutely incredible.
这是一起特别令人毛骨悚然的罪案，涉案人员的年龄简直令人难以置信。
One of the things that's so amazing about watching these old newscasts is how even now, even after these four men have been completely cleared and the real killers have not only confessed on video but been matched with crime scene DNA, even now, you watch that old footage and you think, thank God they caught those terrible kids. You see them in handcuffs, you hear they confessed, and then there's the details of the crime, which seem so believably specific.
观看这些旧新闻报道最令人震惊的一点是，即使在今天，即使在这四名男子已被完全洗清冤屈，且真正的凶手不仅在视频中供述，而且与现场DNA完全匹配之后，你再看那些旧画面时，还是会想，感谢上帝，他们抓住了那些可怕的孩子。你看到他们戴着手铐，听到他们认罪，还有那些罪行的细节，看起来如此具体且令人信服。
Police say at one point, Miss Roscetti was able to break loose from the gang and tried to run away.
警方称，罗斯切蒂小姐曾一度从团伙手中挣脱并试图逃跑。
Lori had been carjacked, police said, at the corner of Loomis and Flournoy. One of her attackers had needed cab fare. They'd all been teenage friends. And then after the first one had raped her, they'd had an argument about who would go next. 15 years later, now that the real killers have confessed, we know all those details are bogus. So where did they come from in the first place?
警方称，洛里是在卢米斯街（Loomis）和弗劳诺伊街（Flournoy）的拐角处被劫持的。其中一名袭击者当时需要打车钱。他们都是青少年时期的朋友。在第一个强奸她之后，他们还为谁下一个轮到而发生了争吵。15年后，现在真正的凶手已经供认，我们知道所有这些细节都是捏造的。那么这些细节最初是从哪里来的呢？
Kathleen Zellner, the four men's attorney, keeps a handgun in her desk and has an air of someone who's seen a lot and wouldn't mind shooting most of it. She discovered where those details came from completely by accident when she noticed a name buried in an old police report. Apparently, the famous FBI profiler Robert Ressler had analyzed the case. That means he'd done what profilers do, which is he'd studied the evidence and made an educated guess, a profile of the sort of suspects the police ought to look for. But this profile wasn't in any of the police reports. And so, because she's Kathleen Zellner, she then flipped to the world famous profiler's name in her Rolodex.
凯瑟琳·泽尔纳（Kathleen Zellner）是这四名男子的辩护律师，她办公桌里常备一把手枪，浑身散发着一种“见多识广、不介意干掉其中大部分人”的气质。她发现这些细节的来源完全是个巧合，当时她在陈旧的警务报告中注意到了一个名字。显然，著名的联邦调查局侧写师罗伯特·雷斯勒（Robert Ressler）曾对该案进行过分析。这意味着他做了侧写师该做的事，即研究证据并做出有根据的猜测，勾勒出警方应该寻找的嫌疑人类型。但这份侧写并没有出现在任何警务报告中。于是，因为她是凯瑟琳·泽尔纳，她就在通讯录里翻到了这位世界著名侧写师的名字。
So I called him at his home. I have his home number. And I called him and I said, "I want to talk to you about the Roscetti case." He said, "I remember that case." He said, "I did a profile on that." And I said, "Yeah, but you didn't write it up." And he said, "Yeah, I did. It's in my book." And I said, "What's your book called?" And he said, "Whoever Fights Monsters." And I said, "I've got that on my bookshelf. Let me put you on hold." I said, "What page is it on?" He knew the page. So I went over and I got the book and I opened it and I thought, my God, I'm looking at the confession.
所以我给他家里打了电话。我有他的家庭号码。我打电话给他，我说：“我想和你聊聊罗斯切蒂案。”他说：“我记得那个案子。”他说：“我做过一份侧写。”我说：“是的，但你没把它写下来。”他说：“写了，在我的书里。”我说：“你的书叫什么名字？”他说：“《谁与怪物博弈》（Whoever Fights Monsters）。”我说：“我的书架上有那本书。我先把你搁置一下。”我说：“是在哪一页？”他知道页码。所以我走过去拿出书翻开，心想，天哪，我正在看那份供词。
Ressler's best guess profile matched exactly what Calvin and Bradford confessed to. To Kathleen, it looked like the police had taken Ressler's scenario, filled it in with some local names and details, forced her clients to sign it, and then called it a confession.
雷斯勒的推测侧写与卡尔文和布拉德福德供述的内容完全吻合。对凯瑟琳来说，看起来就像是警察采纳了雷斯勒的剧本，填入了一些当地的名字和细节，强迫她的当事人签下，然后称之为供词。
Whoever Fights Monsters by Robert Ressler, page 166. "My guess was based on what I thought was likely to have happened after Roscetti had left the garage. She probably stopped at a light in this run-down district and some people came up to her, locked the car, and one pulled a door, which happened to be open. To my mind, this had been an opportunistic crime. The attempt to rob had been a primary motivator and the sexual assault was secondary.
罗伯特·雷斯勒所著《谁与怪物博弈》第166页。“我的猜测是基于我认为罗斯切蒂离开车库后可能发生的情况。她可能在这个破败地区的红绿灯前停了下来，有些人走近她，锁住车门，其中一人拉开了车门，当时车门恰好没锁。在我看来，这是一起机会主义犯罪。抢劫动机是首要的，性侵是次要的。”
It was subsequently learned that the reason Miss Roscetti was victimized originally was because one of the four offenders needed money to get to his home in Cabrini-Green. And the group had decided to rob the first person who comes along.
后来了解到，罗斯切蒂小姐最初受害的原因是四名罪犯中的一人需要钱回卡布里尼-格林（Cabrini-Green）的家。于是该团伙决定抢劫遇到的第一个人。
Detectives will not reveal the specifics of how the case was solved. Meanwhile, police are now searching for a fourth suspect. Steve Sanders, WGN News.
侦探们不会透露该案是如何破获的具体细节。同时，警方目前正在搜寻第四名嫌疑人。史蒂夫·桑德斯（Steve Sanders），WGN新闻报道。
When the real killers were caught, they explained what actually happened. They jumped Lori Roscetti in an alley near her house, not at the corner Loomis and Flournoy. There were only two of them, not four. They were adults, not teenagers. And neither needed money to get home.
当真正的凶手被抓获时，他们解释了实际发生的情况。他们是在洛里·罗斯切蒂家附近的小巷里袭击了她，而不是在卢米斯和弗劳诺伊的拐角处。只有两个人，而不是四个人。他们是成年人，而不是青少年。而且谁也不需要钱回家。
The Chicago Police declined to be interviewed for this story. Because of pending lawsuits, they're not commenting publicly on the case. But if the original defendants are to be believed, what happened next, in 1987, was this. The police didn't just sell their version of the crime to the TV stations. They also tried to sell it to some possible witnesses. Omar Saunders says he was brought to the Area 4 headquarters on February 11 by detectives James Mercurio and Thomas Lamb. Omar says it soon became clear what they wanted from him.
芝加哥警方拒绝就此报道接受采访。由于悬而未决的诉讼，他们不对该案发表公开评论。但如果最初的被告所言属实，接下来在1987年发生的事情就是这样的：警方不仅向电视台兜售了他们版本的罪行。他们还试图将其推销给一些可能的目击者。奥马尔·桑德斯（Omar Saunders）说，他在2月11日被侦探詹姆斯·梅库里奥（James Mercurio）和托马斯·兰姆（Thomas Lamb）带到了第4区总部。奥马尔说，他们想要他做什么很快就明朗了。
This is detective Mercurio and his partner Lamb telling me, "We want you to say that on the night of this crime, you was breaking into some railroad cars. You was attempting to break into some railroad cars and you heard a scream. And you began to walk towards the direction of Ashland where you heard the screams. And as you got closer, you noticed four black guys and a white--" This was their words. Four black guys and a white broad. This was their words. I'm like, "I'm not saying that."
这是侦探梅库里奥和他的搭档兰姆告诉我：“我们要你说是案发当晚，你在撬几节火车车厢。你试图撬开火车车厢，然后听到了一声尖叫。你开始朝你听到尖叫声的阿什兰（Ashland）方向走去。当你走近时，你注意到四个黑人和一个白人……”这是他们的原话。“四个黑人和一个白人妞”。这是他们的原话。我说：“我才不这么说。”
So basically, they wanted you to say that you were a witness to seeing these other guys committing the crime?
所以基本上，他们是想让你说你目击了其他人作案？
Exactly. I would have not even been arrested for this case had I went on ahead and took the deal.
正是如此。如果我当时答应了这个交易，我甚至都不会因为这个案子被捕。
But, of course, by refusing to tell the detectives what they wanted to hear, he didn't take the deal and he, along with Larry and Calvin, got charged with the murder.
但当然，因为拒绝按照侦探的要求去说，他没能达成交易，他和拉里、卡尔文一起被控谋杀。
Do you think they ever, even in the very beginning, ever thought that you were really involved and then took it so far where they couldn't backtrack? They got in too deep an had to cover it up. Or do you think they never thought you were involved and it was just straight from the beginning a massive fraud?
你认为他们一开始是否真的觉得你卷入了案件，然后事情发展到无法回头？他们陷入太深，不得不掩盖？还是你认为他们从一开始就没觉得你卷入其中，这纯粹是一场大规模的欺诈？
I'm convinced, from what I went through and what I know today that they never once thought that I was guilty.
我深信，根据我的经历以及我今天所知道的一切，他们一次都没觉得我有罪。
Omar, Larry, and Calvin all had separate trials and uphill legal fights. Remember, the crime's details were ugly, the case was big news, and the state's attorney, Richard Daley-- current mayor, by the way-- really, really, didn't want to lose. Omar's powerfully built with a shaved head, a huge grin, and an easy charisma. He remembers sitting at the defendant's table with the victim's family seated behind him.
奥马尔、拉里和卡尔文都分别经历了审判和艰难的法律抗争。记住，案情很丑陋，新闻闹得很大，而当时的州检察官理查德·戴利（Richard Daley）——顺便说一句，就是现在的市长——真的、真的不想输。奥马尔身材魁梧，剃着光头，笑容灿烂，有着一种从容的个人魅力。他记得坐在被告席上，受害者的家人就坐在他身后。
If eyes could kill, I'd have been dead. I'd have turned into a pillar of salt because it was-- and it's only justifiable that people were feeling that way because they were misled. But I was sitting in that courtroom and I knew I wasn't supposed to be sitting there.
如果眼神能杀人，我早就死了。我会被变成一根盐柱，因为……人们有那种感受也是情有可原的，因为他们被误导了。但我坐在那间法庭里，我知道我不该坐在那儿。
And was your family there?
你的家人在场吗？
No, nobody. I had one cousin. Her name was Iyo. She showed up with her son, Brandon. People, for me, didn't even want to show up in the courtroom because it was always filled with people from the victim. In fact, the day, I think, when I got sentenced. No, I was going for sentencing. And I was listening to WGCI, if I'm correct, they was talking about our case. It was early in the morning. They said, "Well, from what I've read, I understand that the Saunders kid likes it cold," meaning that I had sex with the victim when she was dead.
没有，没人在。我有一个表亲，名字叫伊约（Iyo）。她带着儿子布兰登出席了。对我来说，人们甚至不想出现在法庭上，因为它总是挤满了受害者那边的人。事实上，我记得在我被判刑那天，或者说我要去接受判刑的那天，如果我没记错的话，我在听WGCI电台，他们正在谈论我们的案子。那是清晨。他们说：“嗯，根据我读到的，我知道桑德斯这孩子喜欢冷的。”意思是说我在受害者死后还和她发生了性关系。
All these listeners listened to him say that. Any little vestige of integrity that I was trying to hold onto, man, they tore my whole character down, destroyed, obliterated it when they said that. Even some of the female associates that I had. They would come and visit me. I could look in their eyes and see they were trying to find the person that had been described over the radio.
所有听众都听他这么说。我试图保持的任何一点正直，伙计，他们撕碎了我的整个人格，当我听到那些话时，他们摧毁并湮灭了它。甚至我认识的一些女性朋友也是。她们来探监时，我能从她们眼睛里看出，她们在试图寻找那个电台上描述的那种人。
All I had to hold on to was the truth that I'm innocent and that the truth is going to prevail. Because at that time, I was reading the Bible very, very hard. And that scripture that said the truth will set you free, I'm just recording that. Know the truth and the truth will set you free. So I'm drawing that, well, there's a God. I'm totally innocent. The jury's going to bring back a not guilty verdict. I don't care what nobody says because I read this book and that's what this book says.
我所能坚持的只有我是清白的这个事实，真理终将胜出。因为当时，我非常努力地研读圣经。那句“真理必叫你们得以自由”的经文，我一直在心里默念。认识真理，真理必叫你们得以自由。所以我正在领悟：噢，上帝是存在的，我是完全清白的，陪审团会做出无罪裁决的。我不在乎别人怎么说，因为我读了这本书，这本书就是这么说的。
At Calvin's trial, things didn't go much better. And at Larry's trial, it was more of the same.
在卡尔文的审判中，情况也没好到哪去。而在拉里的审判中，更是如出一辙。
You don't think that some rinky-dink cop that goes to some neighborhood, "Somebody saw a license plate. Let me knock on these doors, ask a few questions," got the power to just make up a story, give it to the media, and the whole world becomes involved in it. Because I saw all this stuff in Time Magazine. My lawyer had the Time Magazine right on the desk. This case, I never thought about them having this much power.
你不会想到，某个到社区里走访的无名小卒警察，“有人看到了车牌号，让我去敲敲门，问几个问题，”就有权编造一个故事，交给媒体，然后全世界都被卷进来了。因为我在《时代周刊》上看到了所有这些内容。我的律师当时就把《时代周刊》放在桌上。这个案子，我从没想过他们竟然有这么大的权力。
The prosecution was slightly hampered by the fact that the men they were prosecuting weren't guilty. Even at the time, the state conceded that the physical evidence was slim. At Calvin's trial, they relied on his confession, even though by then he'd taken it back. At Larry's trial, they relied on Marcellius Bradford.
检方因被告无罪这一事实而略显尴尬。即使在当时，州政府也承认物证稀薄。在卡尔文的审判中，他们依赖他的供词，尽管在那之前他已经翻供了。在拉里的审判中，他们依赖马塞勒斯·布拉德福德。
Marcellius Bradford is the one defendant in the case who you won't be hearing from. The reason is that, after being released in 1992, he got rearrested on shoplifting charges in 1998 and is still locked up. He was out in the first place, of course, because he'd cut this deal with the prosecutors. They'd agreed to drop some charges. He'd agreed to testify against Larry, which meant he'd have to take the stand, stare out at his friend, tell the whole world how they'd raped and murdered Lori Roscetti, and all Larry could do was sit and listen.
马塞勒斯·布拉德福德是案件中你听不到其声音的被告。原因是在1992年获释后，他因商店行窃于1998年再次被捕，目前仍在狱中。当初他能出来，是因为他和检察官达成了这笔交易。他们同意撤销一些指控。他同意指证拉里，这意味着他必须站上证人席，盯着他的朋友，向全世界讲述他们是如何强奸和杀害洛里·罗斯切蒂的，而拉里能做的只是坐在那儿听着。
Bradford, man, told them all of this stuff. And it was just weird because I knew everything he was saying was false. And he knew everything he was saying was false. And it was just amazing to see how that can really take place. You sit up there and say you actually did all those things that you know you didn't do, you know I didn't do. You could change this whole thing around right now. Just tell them it didn't happen. That'd change the whole complexity of the whole trial. "Wait a minute, what you doing, Bradford? Hold on, your honor, I would like to have a five-minute recess." And he would've been like, "No, let this play on out." Threw the whole jury for a loop. But that didn't take place.
布拉德福德那家伙，告诉了他们所有这些事情。这很奇怪，因为我知道他说的每一件事都是假的。他也知道他说的每一件事都是假的。看到这一切真的发生了，真是令人震惊。你坐在上面，说你自己真的做了所有那些你知道你没做、我知道我也没做的事情。你本可以在那一刻扭转一切。只要告诉他们那没发生。那会改变整个审判的复杂性。“等一下，布拉德福德，你在干什么？等等，法官大人，我想休息五分钟。”而他本会说：“不，让这出戏演下去。”让陪审团彻底晕头转向。但那并没有发生。
The day that the jury returned the verdict--
陪审团归还裁决的那天——
Here's Omar.
这是奥马尔。
--they had a paper and they handed to the bailiff and the bailiff handed it to the judge. The judge was looking at it. And he looked up and he said, "This is your verdict." And I was so shocked. Because there was women in the jury box that actually smiled at me one time when a certain witness was on the stand. He was caught in lies. And she was shaking her head like this is crazy. And I was just sure I had that juror on my side.
——他们拿着一张纸交给法警，法警把它递给了法官。法官看着它。他抬起头说：“这就是你们的裁决。”我感到非常震惊。因为陪审团里有女性曾在我的一位证人出庭时朝我笑过。他当时当场被戳穿了谎言。而她摇着头，表情仿佛在说这太荒唐了。我当时非常确定那位陪审员站在我这一边。
Anyway, when they all answered guilty, guilty, guilty, I just put my head down and a deep resentment and anger took over. I put one of my feet up on the table. That was my way to prevent myself from crying in front of the world. The anger. After they escorted me out of the courtroom, I went in the back, and that's when I let the tears roll. I was like, "man, they found me guilty for this."
总之，当他们所有人都回答“有罪，有罪，有罪”时，我只是低下了头，一种深深的怨恨和愤怒占据了内心。我把一只脚抬到桌上。那是阻止我在全世界面前哭出来的办法。愤怒。在他们把我从法庭押送出来后，我到了后面，那才是我让眼泪流下来的时候。我当时想：“伙计，他们竟然判我有罪。”
Calvin, Omar, and Larry got life, only because they were too young for capital punishment. At Larry's sentencing, the judge said, "If any crime ever called out for the death penalty, it's this one. I want to make certain you never walk the streets of this city or any other city again." Bradford, for framing his friends, got a 12-year deal, though years later, he'd tell a reporter, "I think about this every day and I will skateboard into hell."
卡尔文、奥马尔和拉里被判终身监禁，只是因为他们当时太年轻，够不上死刑。在拉里的宣判上，法官说：“如果有什么罪行需要处以死刑，那就是这一件。我要确保你永远不会再踏上这座城市或任何其他城市的街道。”布拉德福德因陷害朋友而获得了12年的刑期，尽管几年后，他告诉一名记者：“我每天都在想这件事，我准备好滑板滑进地狱了。”
When you go to prison, you in a zone full of predators. Real, live predators that's looking for a weakness in some person.
当你进了监狱，你就进入了一个充满掠食者的地带。真正的、活生生的掠食者，正在寻找某个人的弱点。
When they arrived in prison, Calvin was 15, Omar 19, Larry 18. Larry felt particularly bewildered.
当他们到达监狱时，卡尔文15岁，奥马尔19岁，拉里18岁。拉里感到特别迷茫。
A lot of guys been there, in and out, in and out, in and out, before I even got there. So it's an environment that they're accustomed to. Soon as they come through the door, they know what to do, know who to get with, all that kind of stuff. I didn't know this stuff. So to me, it was almost like being a rabbit and trying to stay clear of a hawk that's way up in the sky that sees me out in the open field.
很多家伙都在那里进进出出，在我进去之前就已经在那儿了。所以这是一个他们习以为常的环境。他们一进门就知道该做什么，知道该跟谁混，所有这些东西。我不知道这些。所以对我来说，感觉就像是一只兔子，试图躲避高空中的老鹰，它在开阔的田野里看见了我。
And I'm just fresh on the news. I've got a bunny tail. My ears are super long. The hawk ain't ate in a week. C'mon, man. And I ain't got no hair on my face. None of this-- I don't even have a scar on my face when I went through that. All I had was a little mole on my face. What's her name? Cindy Crawford was just becoming big. She got one, and they freaking off of her. Her poster's on people's walls in jail. This is just real. I'm telling you what's real. And guys think like that and get to lusting after you. You can become that kind of prey.
我刚上新闻不久。我有一条兔子尾巴。我的耳朵超级长。那只鹰已经一个星期没吃东西了。别这样，伙计。而且我脸上还没长胡子。没这些……我进去的时候连脸上疤都没有。我只有脸上一颗小痣。她的名字叫什么？辛迪·克劳馥（Cindy Crawford）当时正红。她有一颗痣，他们迷死她了。她的海报贴在监狱里人们的墙上。这是真实的。我告诉你什么才是真实的。那些家伙就那么想，开始对你产生欲望。你可能就会变成那种猎物。
When I came to Joliet, I was automatically fearful--
当我来到乔利埃特（Joliet）监狱时，我自然而然地感到恐惧——
This is Omar.
这是奥马尔。
--and aggressive because I was angry. My logic was weak. For me to process what happened to me, I just categorize one race. White people is evil. That was my generalization. Everybody that did this to us was white. Can you imagine from my perspective? The policeman was white. The victim was white. The judge was white. The prosecuting attorney was white. Everybody was white that done this. That's the only way I can process it. They're just naturally evil. But as I got older and the time went on in prison, I began to see that evil didn't have a color.
——而且具有攻击性，因为我很愤怒。我的逻辑很软弱。为了消化发生在我身上的事，我只能给一个种族归类。白人是邪恶的。那是我的概括。所有对我们做这件事的人都是白人。你能想象吗，从我的角度？警察是白人。受害者是白人。法官是白人。检察官是白人。做这件事的每个人都是白人。这是我唯一能理解的方式。他们天生邪恶。但随着我年龄增长，监狱时光流逝，我开始看到邪恶是没有颜色的。
Over time, they all found ways to cope. Omar lifted weights and read law books. Larry studied his transcripts. Calvin shot pool. But there were certain things they never got used to. For instance, here's something you never think about with prisons. You're basically locked in a teeny room with another person, a couple of beds, and a toilet.
随着时间的推移，他们都找到了应对的方法。奥马尔举重和阅读法律书籍。拉里研究他的案卷。卡尔文打台球。但有些事情他们永远无法适应。例如，这是你对监狱绝不会想到的事情。你基本上和一个陌生人锁在极小的房间里，几张床，一个马桶。
You could really call them cells a bathroom.
你真可以管那种牢房叫浴室。
And I remember nights when I was in the cell and my celly--
我记得有几个晚上，我在牢房里，我的室友——
You know, his cellmate.
你知道，就是他的狱友。
--got up and used the bathroom, I just woke up because [LAUGHTER]
——起身去上厕所，我就醒了，因为[笑声]
That's rough.
那太难受了。
And the toilet's right by the bed. Just imagine you going to the bathroom and I'm sleeping in the bathroom. I'm sleeping right there.
马桶就在床边。想象一下你上厕所，而我就在厕所里睡觉。我直接在那儿睡。
I used to sleep with the blanket over my eyes. Conditioned myself to sleep with the sheet or a blanket over my head just for that occasion. Just in case my celly get up tonight.
我以前总是用毯子蒙住眼睛睡觉。训练自己用床单或毯子蒙住头睡觉，就为了那种情况。以防我室友半夜起来。
Maybe it's because they were innocent. Maybe it's the sort of thing lots of prisoners figure out. But Omar says that after a while, even though everyone around them claimed to be innocent, it wasn't hard to tell who actually was. They just stuck out.
也许是因为他们是清白的。也许这是许多囚犯都能看出来的事情。但奥马尔说，过了一段时间，即使周围每个人都声称自己是清白的，分辨出谁是真的并不难。他们就是显得格格不入。
I think I was able to sense it from watching guys' actions. Actions spoke louder than their words. They would act like they were free. They woud go to the law library. Always in the library fighting their case. They walk with a sense of integrity. You see it in their eyes, that same spirit that burn like your own do.
我想我能通过观察家伙们的行动感觉到这一点。行动胜过言语。他们会表现得好像自己是自由的。他们会去法学图书馆。总是在图书馆里抗争他们的案子。他们走路时带着一种正直感。你在他们眼里能看到，那种和你自己灵魂一样燃烧的精神。
Unfortunately, even though they could see innocence in other prisoners, other prisoners couldn't always see it in them. Other prisoners thought they were rapists. And being a rapist in prison isn't good. It makes other prisoners want to attack you. Because if there's one thing prisoners miss in prison, it's women.
不幸的是，尽管他们能看出其他囚犯的清白，其他囚犯却不一定能看出他们的清白。其他囚犯以为他们是强奸犯。而在监狱里当强奸犯可不好。这会让其他囚犯想攻击你。因为如果说囚犯在监狱里错过了一样东西，那就是女人。
So guys learn this stuff when they get snatched away from women and get put in the penitentiary. So you come in there for taking what they miss and what they learned to have love and respect for, they're willing to bring all kind of harm to you at will at the blink of an eye, when your psychology least expects.
所以家伙们一旦被从女人身边抢走，被关进监狱，就学会了这些。当你进来的时候，因为做了他们错过的事情，也就是他们学会去爱和尊重的对象，他们愿意在转眼间随时随地对你造成各种伤害，当你心理最没防备的时候。
To Larry and Omar, this was a reoccurring event. They'd be in the showers, or in the yard, or just about anywhere at any time, and they'd get attacked. In one fight, maybe a dozen guys came at them with ice picks and Omar got stabbed 14 times.
对拉里和奥马尔来说，这是一个反复发生的事件。他们在淋浴间、在操场，或任何时候的任何地方，都会遭到攻击。在一次斗殴中，可能有十几个人拿着冰镐冲向他们，奥马尔被捅了14刀。
A quick review. DNA testing first started making its way into criminal court cases in the late '80s. By the mid-'90s, cases of DNA testing getting innocent guys out of prison were starting to make headlines and prisoners everywhere were following the news. Larry got excited. Omar wasn't convinced. He'd become the group's unofficial lawyer by then. He'd written appeals, sent letters to journalists and civil rights groups, attacked various parts of the prosecution's testimony, and no one wrote back. Or when they did write back, they wrote things like the judge, who called Omar's last petition frivolous and patently without merit.
快速回顾一下。DNA测试是在80年代末首次进入刑事法庭案件。到90年代中期，DNA测试让无辜者出狱的案件开始登上头条，各地的囚犯都在关注新闻。拉里很兴奋。奥马尔则不以为然。到那时他已经成了小组的非正式律师。他写过上诉，给记者和民权组织寄过信，攻击过检方证词的各个部分，但没人回信。或者当他们回信时，他们写的是诸如那位法官那样的话，他称奥马尔的最后一次请愿轻浮且明显毫无价值。
Larry didn't care. He kept returning to a single key point. Based on biological evidence found at the crime scene, the prosecution knew the blood type of Lori Roscetti's murderers. The murderers were a blood type called O secreter. To Larry, there'd always been something sketchy about that part of the case and the testimony of the crime lab expert, Pamela Fish. But whenever he'd try to bring this up, Omar would shake his head. Until one day, Omar says.
拉里不在乎。他不断回到一个关键点。根据在犯罪现场发现的生物学证据，检方知道洛里·罗斯切蒂凶手的血型。凶手是O型分泌者。对拉里来说，案件的那一部分以及犯罪实验室专家帕梅拉·菲什（Pamela Fish）的证词一直有些可疑。但每当他想提起这个时，奥马尔就会摇头。直到有一天，奥马尔说。
I think it was in '98. We was in the yard. And Larry was telling me, he said, "Man, Omar." He called me O. "Man, O, we've got to put something in court, man." And I said, "Man, I done tried everything. And there ain't nothing working. Every little thing, they're shooting it down." And Larry said, "Man, I'm telling you, it's the semen."
我想是在98年。我们在操场上。拉里告诉我，他说：“伙计，奥马尔。”他叫我O。“伙计，O，我们得在法庭上提交点东西。”我说：“伙计，我什么都试过了。没用。每一件小事，他们都给驳回了。”拉里说：“伙计，我告诉你，是精液。”
Among the many things that jump out at you here is just how quickly you can get used to a word like semen, especially if it's the key to your freedom and you talk about it every day.
这里跳出来的许多事情中，让你吃惊的是你能多快适应像“精液”这样的词，特别是如果它是你自由的关键，而且你每天都在谈论它的话。
And he was real tentative when he was stating it because he knew how I felt about this. We had separate trials, and in my trial, they said that the semen was consistent with Calvin, Larry, and Bradford.
他在说的时候非常犹豫，因为他知道我对这事的感受。我们进行了分开审判，在我的审判中，他们说精液与卡尔文、拉里和布拉德福德的情况一致。
Meaning the semen found at the crime scene was the same blood type as Calvin, Larry, and Bradford's.
意思是犯罪现场发现的精液与卡尔文、拉里和布拉德福德的血型相同。
And I'm like, is it a possibility I'm the only one innocent? That started to set in. I'm like, damn, you know? And Larry, this particular day, he was just insistent about the semen. "I'm telling you, it's the--" I'm like, "No, it ain't the semen. Because at my trial, the woman said it was consistent with all three of you all. I'm the only one excluded." He said, "No, that ain't what she said at my trial."
我在想，难道我是唯一清白的人？这念头开始沉淀。我在想，该死，你知道吗？拉里那一天非常坚持提到精液。“我告诉你，是……”我说：“不，不是精液。因为在我的审判中，那个女人说它与你们三个人一致。我是唯一被排除的。”他说：“不，她在我的审判里可不是这么说的。”
At Larry's trial, the prosecution admitted that the semen found at the scene didn't match Larry either.
在拉里的审判中，检方承认在现场发现的精液也不匹配拉里。
And that stuck with me. Wait a minute. You sure? I'm like, "Send me your trial transcript of Pamela Fish's testimony so I can read it myself." And when he sent me her trial transcript testimony, my eyes watered up because legally, I knew what it meant. We free.
那让我陷入沉思。等一下。你确定？我说：“把你的帕梅拉·菲什证词审判笔录寄给我，让我自己读。”当我读到她的证词记录时，我的眼眶湿润了，因为从法律上讲，我知道这意味着什么。我们自由了。
What they'd discovered was this. The prosecution had given conflicting testimony. Its crime lab expert, Pamela Fish, had made it seem like at least one of them matched up with the semen found at the crime scene. In fact, none of them did. To move ahead, however, to move one step closer to getting out, they needed Calvin's signature on an affidavit verifying his blood type, verifying that he was also a non-secretor just like them. It couldn't be simpler, except for one problem. Calvin wouldn't sign.
他们发现的是：检方提供了相互矛盾的证词。其犯罪实验室专家帕梅拉·菲什曾让法庭觉得，他们中至少有一人与现场发现的精液相符。事实上，他们中没有一人相符。然而，要向前迈进，为了离获释更近一步，他们需要卡尔文在宣誓书上签名，验证他的血型，证明他也是一名非分泌者，就像他们一样。这再简单不过了，除了一个问题。卡尔文拒绝签字。
I was sitting in my room one night and all of the sudden I got a letter from Omar, "Sign this piece of paper. " I'm like, "No, I'm not going to sign this piece of paper, man."
我有一天晚上坐在房间里，突然收到奥马尔的信：“在这张纸上签名。”我说：“不，伙计，我才不在那张纸上签名呢。”
Calvin, tell about why you don't sign pieces of paper.
卡尔文，说说为什么你不签文件。
It's how I got locked up. Last time I signed a piece of paper, I went to jail for life.
那是怎么让我被锁进去的。上次我签了文件，我就被判了终身监禁。
And what was that piece of paper you signed?
那你签的那份文件是什么？
Confessions that the police made up and had me sign.
警察伪造的让我签名的认罪书。
He wrote them back a letter explaining his new policy on signing his name. Omar couldn't believe it.
他回信解释了他的签名新原则。奥马尔不敢相信。
I remember that letter. Yeah, I know man. You were saying, "I got your affidavit. I'm sorry to let you know that I can't sign y'all affidavit." He called it y'all affidavit. "Y'all affidavit. And I just want to let you all know that I accept the Lord Jesus Christ as my personal lord and savior and I wish you all well." Larry cried. I'll never forget this. Larry cried when he read that letter because Calvin was putting it on, "I don't want to sign nothing. I'll put my faith totally in God. That's it."
我记得那封信。是的，我知道伙计。你说：“我收到了你们的宣誓书。很遗憾地通知你们，我不能签你们的宣誓书。”他管它叫“你们的宣誓书”。“你们的宣誓书。我只想让你们知道，我已经接受主耶稣基督作为我的个人救主，祝你们一切顺利。”拉里哭了。我永远不会忘记这一点。拉里读那封信时哭了，因为卡尔文正在搞，“我什么都不想签。我会把我的信仰完全交给上帝。就是这样。”
And I was trying to find a way how can I reach him and make him understand that that ain't the way the God I believe in works. Your faith in God is good, but act on it. You can't say you believe in no God and don't believe in your own ability to think, reason, and understand because he gave you a brain to do just that with.
我当时试图寻找一种方法，怎么才能触动他，让他明白那不是我所信仰的上帝的运作方式。你对上帝的信仰是好的，但要付诸行动。你不能说你相信上帝，却不相信自己思考、推理和理解的能力，因为他给了你大脑来做这些事。
In the end, to make a long story short, Calvin signed. They now had the documents to prove that none of them were the same blood type as the killers. But just getting a judge to look at this new evidence was a huge long shot. And it's not as if they'd been so successful at filing their own appeals. Then, one day, Omar came across a magazine profile of a trial lawyer named Kathleen Zellner. She was in the business of getting wrongfully convicted men out of prison. She liked DNA cases in particular, and then suing the state for big bucks.
最后，长话短说，卡尔文签了字。他们现在有了文件证明他们谁的血型都和凶手不同。但仅仅想让法官看这些新证据，机会就非常渺茫。而且这并不是说他们在提交自己的上诉时有多成功。然后有一天，奥马尔在杂志上看到了一位名叫凯瑟琳·泽尔纳的庭审律师的简介。她从事的是让被错误定罪的人出狱的业务。她特别喜欢DNA案件，然后起诉州政府赚取大笔钱。
When I saw Miss Zellner in the magazine, it was like, "This is is who we need. We need her." Because you can see she's like a hawk. When she sees something, she focuses in on it. So I knew if I could get her to see what Larry caused me to see, this thing's going to be electric. And I just began to construct the letter based on the facts about us all being non-secretors and that the killer is an O secretor.
当我看到泽尔纳女士在杂志上时，我想：“这就是我们需要的人。我们需要她。”因为你可以看出她就像一只鹰。当她看到目标时，她就专注在上面。所以我知道如果我能让她看到拉里让我看到的东西，这事儿就会像闪电一样。我开始根据我们所有人都是非分泌者而凶手是O型分泌者这些事实来构建那封信。
Then, with the facts that I was saying, I put in the what if. What if what I'm saying is true-- everything that I'm saying is true? What would be the repercussions? What would be the financial benefits for everybody involved? I know you're an attorney. I know you've got things that you've got to do. You don't want people taking up your time. This is a profession. This is something that you like doing. Well, here go the perfect case.
然后，伴随着我所说的事实，我加入了“如果”。如果我说的是真的——我所说的一切都是真的？后果会是什么？对每个相关人员有什么财务好处？我知道你是律师。我知道你有必须要做的事情。你不想让人们浪费你的时间。这是一种职业。这是你喜欢做的事。那么，完美的案子来了。
We are going to interrupt [UNINTELLIGIBLE] report for just a moment to bring you this special update. Moments ago, two of those three men wrongfully imprisoned for a rape/murder in 1986 were set free.
我们将中断[听不清]报道片刻，为大家带来这份特别更新。片刻前，那三名因1986年强奸/谋杀案被错误囚禁的男子中有两人被释放。
Let's go live there now.
让我们现在直播连线那里。
I've prepared a statement for the press. First, I would like to thank God for returning to us our freedom and for bringing into our struggle our attorney Miss Zellner and her associates--"
我已经为媒体准备了一份声明。首先，我要感谢上帝将我们的自由还给了我们，并感谢我们的律师泽尔纳女士及其同事加入我们的斗争——”
On December 5 of 2001, Omar, Larry, and Calvin were finally released. 15 years after their original arrests. 18 months after Kathleen Zellner received Omar's letter. She'd logged 800 unpaid hours and spent $50,000 of her own money to get the case back in court. Along the way, she'd had an independent lab test her clients' DNA and none of it matched the DNA from the crime scene. Faced with this new evidence, the state's attorney let them out. The footage that you're hearing is from the press conference outside the prison.
2001年12月5日，奥马尔、拉里和卡尔文终于获释。距离他们最初被捕已经过去了15年。距离凯瑟琳·泽尔纳收到奥马尔的信也过去了18个月。她记录了800小时的无偿工作，并自掏腰包5万美元，才让案件重回法庭。在此过程中，她让一家独立实验室对她客户的DNA进行了测试，没有任何一个与犯罪现场的DNA匹配。面对这一新证据，州检察官放了他们。你现在听到的音频来自监狱外的记者会。
--police. They're intimating that you were still involved somehow.
——警察。他们暗示你们仍然以某种方式参与其中。
Well, I believe that they've got to stand on their position. They know the facts about-- now you all did a great job in revealing the facts, so I think they know what's coming. I used to quote a statement, that the heavens ablaze with light and the distant thunder seem to herald forth a coming storm. And they know that the storm is coming. That's the truth about this case. So they can say what they want to say. But it'll bear out in the future proceedings in another courtroom.
嗯，我相信他们必须坚持自己的立场。他们知道关于——现在你们所有人都很出色地揭露了事实，所以我认为他们知道即将发生什么。我过去常引用一句话，当天空被光芒照亮，远处的雷声预示着一场即将来临的风暴。他们知道风暴要来了。这就是这起案件的真相。所以他们想说什么就说什么。但这将在另一个法庭的未来诉讼中得到证实。
What's missing from this press conference is a review of how many things could have happened to keep these guys from getting out. Before Omar wrote to Kathleen, for example, he wrote to the nation's best known wrongful conviction expert, Barry Scheck. Barry Scheck contacted the police about reviewing the Roscetti case evidence. The police told Barry Scheck that the evidence had been destroyed. Which means that if Kathleen Zellner hadn't had an inside court contact agree to double check for the supposedly destroyed evidence, and if upon finding that evidence Kathleen's contact hadn't agreed to keep it hidden in her desk, all could have been lost.
这次记者会上缺少的是对有多少事情可能阻止他们获释的回顾。例如，在奥马尔写信给凯瑟琳之前，他曾写信给全国最著名的冤案专家巴里·谢克（Barry Scheck）。巴里·谢克联系了警方，要求复核罗斯切蒂案的证据。警方告诉巴里·谢克证据已经被销毁了。这意味着如果凯瑟琳·泽尔纳没有一个内部法院的联系人同意复查那些据说被销毁的证据，并且如果找到证据后凯瑟琳的联系人没同意将其藏在办公桌里，那么一切都可能彻底丧失。
And that's just the beginning. Omar's letter to Kathleen could have never been read. Larry could have decided not to press his seminal insight that day in the yard. Calvin's faith in the Lord might have stopped him from signing that affidavit. Any one of them could have been killed in jail. And then there's the most likely thing that could have happened. They could have just lost hope.
而那仅仅是个开始。奥马尔写给凯瑟琳的信可能永远没被读过。拉里可能那天在操场上决定不坚持他关于精液的洞察。卡尔文对主的信仰可能阻止了他签署那份宣誓书。他们中的任何一个人都可能在监狱里被杀。还有最可能发生的事情：他们可能已经失去了希望。
Did you ever give up hope?
你曾经失去过希望吗？
Did I ever give up hope? No, I don't think I ever actually gave up completely. But there was a time I felt like I wanted to give up. Any other questions I would like to refer to my attorney.
我曾经失去过希望吗？不，我不认为我曾经真正完全放弃过。但有段时间我确实想过放弃。任何其他问题我想请教我的律师。
Around the country there are thousands of cases in which people are reexamining DNA evidence. Maybe tens of thousands. But as of December, 2001, the month Calvin, Larry, and Omar got released, only 98 people had ever been released from prison based on DNA. It's still hard to get out of prison. Nearly all of those 98 had been convicted for sex crimes, which makes sense if you think about it. Those are the crimes where it's most likely that the biological evidence is still around somewhere to be tested, as it was in Omar, Larry, and Calvin's case.
在全国各地，有数千起案件中人们正在重新审视DNA证据。也许有数万起。但截至2001年12月，也就是卡尔文、拉里和奥马尔获释的那个月，只有98人曾经基于DNA证据获释。出狱依然很难。这98人中几乎所有人都是被判性犯罪的，如果你仔细想想，这说得通。在这些案件中，生物学证据最有可能还在某个地方可以被检测，就像奥马尔、拉里和卡尔文的案件那样。
In the months since their release, Omar, Larry, and Calvin have had to enter a new world full of big and small firsts. First time writing checks. First time taking driving tests. First time for Larry getting really lost. Now they call him Compass. First time for Omar getting in a fender bender. Now they call him Crash. And Calvin, in a first of his own, tried to adopt a cat only to be screened out by an animal control clerk who denied his application because he lacked a job history.
在获释后的几个月里，奥马尔、拉里和卡尔文不得不进入一个充满大小“第一次”的新世界。第一次开支票。第一次参加驾照考试。拉里第一次真正迷路了。现在他们叫他“指南针”。奥马尔第一次发生了轻微的车辆刮蹭。现在他们叫他“撞车手”。而卡尔文，在他自己的第一次尝试中，试图领养一只猫，结果被动物控制部门的工作人员拒绝了，因为他缺乏就业记录。
And then there's their obsession with pictures. Almost every time I visited, they wanted to take pictures or they wanted to show me pictures of people they'd recently met. Lots of them were basically strangers, like kids they'd talked to at a high school. But after 15 years in prison, it sort of makes sense. They don't have a history, and so they're filling photo albums trying to catch up.
还有他们对照片的痴迷。几乎每次我访问，他们都想拍照或者展示给我看他们最近遇到的人的照片。很多基本上是陌生人，比如他们在高中交谈过的孩子们。但在监狱里待了15年后，这倒也说得通。他们没有过去的历史，所以他们在填满相册，试图追赶上生活。
The last time producer Alex Blumberg and I sat down with Omar in Kathleen Zellner's suburban office, we ended up having a long chat about the Declaration of Independence. Omar had read it in prison.
最后一次制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）和我与奥马尔坐在凯瑟琳·泽尔纳的郊区办公室里，我们最终关于《独立宣言》进行了长谈。奥马尔在监狱里读过它。
When I read that document, I was like, wow, that it actually incorporates rebelling against an oppressive government. If the government becomes too oppressive, the power is actually in our hands. That's why when you talk to anybody that claims-- especially these people that speak about the American character and what we should do-- you should ask them, "Let me hear you recite the Declaration of Independence."
当我读那份文件时，我是说，哇，它实际上包含了反抗压迫政府的内容。如果政府变得太压迫，权力实际上是在我们手中。这就是为什么当你和任何声称——特别是那些谈论美国特性以及我们应该做什么的人——谈话时，你应该问他们：“让我听听你背诵一下《独立宣言》。”
Omar looks over at us and recites from memory.
奥马尔看着我们并凭记忆背诵。
"We hold these truths to be self-evident that all men are created equal, and are endowed by their creator with certain inalienable rights and that among these are life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness." And you will come to find out that the average American don't even know it.
“我们认为这些真理是不言而喻的：人人生而平等，造物主赋予他们若干不可剥夺的权利，其中包括生存权、自由权和追求幸福的权利。”你会发现普通美国人甚至根本不知道它。
What was that like to read that document and know in light of what had happened to you, is that-- it sounds like what you were just saying is that it actually made it seem like America's actually on your side.
读这份文件是什么感觉？鉴于你所经历的事情，这听起来像你刚刚说的，它实际上让你觉得美国实际上是站在你这一边的。
America is all-- the concepts and principles on which the country is founded has always been on our side.
美国……这个国家所建立的概念和原则一直都是站在我们这一边的。
You talk about what you like when you went in. And it almost sounds like you've had this horrific miscarriage of justice done against you. And here you are on the other side of it. And you have more respect for the system than maybe when you went in, in a way.
你谈到你进去时喜欢的东西。听起来你遭受了一场可怕的司法不公。而现在你站在了它的另一面。某种程度上，你对这个系统比你进去时更有尊重。
Yeah, because I understand that it's a lack of understanding the system that caused this. It's like if the police do something to me, I ain't going to go blow up the whole Chicago police force because you've got a lot of good Chicago policemen. That's why I always say that the media said that we got out and we spoke vehemently against the system. I never spoke against the system. I love America. I understand that the system don't operate itself. It's people. There ain't nothing wrong. America's got one of the greatest jurisprudence systems in the world. Some countries, when you do something, they kill you. Ain't nothing to talk about. See?
是的，因为我理解正是对系统的缺乏理解导致了这一切。就像如果警察对我做了什么，我不会去炸掉整个芝加哥警察部队，因为你有很多优秀的芝加哥警察。这就是为什么我总是说，媒体报道说我们出来了，然后愤怒地反对这个系统。我从来没有反对过这个系统。我爱美国。我明白系统不会自己运作。是人。这没问题。美国拥有世界上最伟大的司法系统之一。有些国家，当你做了什么，他们就杀了你。没什么好谈的。看见没？
So my whole view today is I understand that if we want to make America a greater place, it's going to take people like us to understand what the nation is based on and do what the Founding Fathers did when they thought that their freedoms were being jeopardized and that their rights were being infringed. You do that by knowing the law. When you don't know something, people can take advantage. This is a beautiful democratic republic.
所以我今天的整体观点是，我理解如果我们要让美国变得更伟大，需要像我们这样的人去理解这个国家是建立在什么之上的，并在开国元勋们认为他们的自由受到威胁、权利受到侵犯时采取行动。你通过了解法律来做到这一点。当你不知道某些事情时，人们就能占你的便宜。这是一个美丽的民主共和国。
One day a few weeks ago I went to court with Larry, Calvin, and Omar. The real killers had some early hearing to show up for. This would be a first chance to see them face to face. But for some reason, the hearing got postponed. Walking out in the hallway of this giant, stone building, Larry, Calvin, and Omar suddenly froze. They stared as a stooped, older man shuffled toward us. Calvin blurted out, "It's Patrick O'Brien."
几周前的一天，我和拉里、卡尔文、奥马尔一起去了法庭。真正的凶手有一些早期的听证会要出席。这将是面对面看到他们的第一次机会。但不知为何，听证会被推迟了。走在这个巨大石头建筑的走廊里，拉里、卡尔文和奥马尔突然僵住了。他们盯着一个驼背的老人朝我们挪过来。卡尔文脱口而出：“是帕特里克·奥布莱恩（Patrick O'Brien）。”
This was the man who'd prosecuted their case, the man who'd called them rapists and murderers, the man who they held most responsible for stealing half their lives. He looked up at them and seemed to experience the same momentary shock. You could see him almost start to turn around, but then it was too late and we were passing by him and he was nodding his head. What he said was, "Gentlemen."
这就是当初起诉他们案子的那个人，称他们为强奸犯和杀人犯的那个人，他们认为最该为偷走他们半生负责的那个人。他抬头看向他们，似乎经历了同样的瞬间震惊。你能看到他几乎开始转过身，但那时太晚了，我们正经过他身边，他点着头。他说的词是：“绅士们。”
Shane DuBow in Chicago. Coming up, how to make a 14-year-old suburban kid confess to the murder of his own sister when he did not do it. In a minute from Public Radio International and Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
芝加哥的肖恩·杜博报道。接下来，如何让一个14岁的郊区孩子承认他并没有犯下的杀害亲妹妹的罪行。稍后从公共广播国际公司和芝加哥公共广播电台收听，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Perfect Evidence. We look at the world that has been revealed to us now thanks to the most perfect evidence in the history of criminology, DNA evidence.
这里是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目是“完美的证据”。我们审视现在多亏了犯罪学史上最完美的证据——DNA证据——而向我们揭示的世界。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Snitch. One of the biggest changes that's come about in this era of overturned convictions and DNA evidence is that we've learned that one kind of evidence that most of us would think it's irrefutable and that historically has been the strongest possible evidence, a person's own confession, might not mean anything. In many wrongful conviction cases, the person who was mistakenly thrown in prison actually was on record confessing the crime. How does this happen?
我们到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，告密者。在这个定罪平反和DNA证据的时代，最大的变化之一是我们了解到，一种我们大多数人认为不可反驳、且历史上最强大的证据——一个人自己的供词——可能毫无意义。在许多冤假错案中，那个被错误关进监狱的人实际上是有认罪记录的。这是怎么发生的？
Well, consider this case. On January 20, 1998, 12-year-old Stephanie Crowe was stabbed to death in her bedroom. There were no signs of forced entry into the house. Nobody heard a burglar. So the police suspected that it was an inside job done by a family member. And at some point, they brought in her 14-year-old brother, Michael. After 11 hours of interrogation, he confessed to the crime, though later, he was cleared when a DNA test found that Stephanie's blood was on a vagrant who'd been wandering around the neighborhood the night of the murder.
嗯，考虑一下这个案件。1998年1月20日，12岁的斯蒂芬妮·克罗（Stephanie Crowe）在卧室被刺死。房子没有强行进入的迹象。没人听到盗贼。所以警方怀疑是家庭内部人员所为。在某个时间点，他们带走了她14岁的哥哥迈克尔。经过11小时审讯，他供认了罪行，尽管后来DNA测试发现斯蒂芬妮的血是在案发当晚在社区流浪的一个流浪汉身上，他因此被洗清罪名。
So how did the police get Michael to confess? Well, for one thing, his parents were not there. They believed that he was in protective custody getting grief counseling. His sister had just died.
那么警方是如何让迈克尔认罪的呢？嗯，首先，他的父母不在场。他们以为他在接受保护性羁押，进行悲伤辅导。他的妹妹刚刚去世。
Richard Leo is a criminologist who has studied false confessions. He reviewed the videotape of the confession with me.
理查德·利奥（Richard Leo）是一位研究虚假供词的犯罪学家。他和我一起复核了那份认罪的录像带。
Virtually every interrogation that I've ever seen of a juvenile, the police try to figure out how to keep parent out of the room. They might tell them that it's not necessary or that they're not allowed to be there or they simply, as in this case, might tell them something false so they have no idea their child is being interrogated.
几乎我见过的每一次对未成年人的审讯，警方都在设法把父母挡在门外。他们可能会告诉他们那没必要，或者他们不允许在那儿，或者就像这个案子，他们干脆告诉他们一些虚假信息，这样他们就不知道自己的孩子正在接受审讯。
At the very beginning of the interrogation, there are two officers. And one comes in and he's a little tougher and he's presenting the evidence and the accusations. And then there's another cop who's acting like the good cop. They're doing a classic good cop, bad cop. And the good cop is saying, "Well, we're trying to believe what you say."
在审讯刚开始时，有两名警官。其中一个进来，表现得强硬一些，提出证据和指控。然后是另一个警察表现得像个好警察。他们正在进行经典的红脸白脸。好警察说：“嗯，我们在努力相信你说的话。”
I'm here to verify what you're saying, OK? We're going to work through this together, OK?
我是来核实你说的，好吗？我们一起来解决这个问题，好吗？
OK.
好的。
I can tell you this instrument here is what they call a computer voice stress analyzer. Now you will appreciate this, being into computers.
我可以告诉你，这个仪器叫做计算机语音压力分析仪。既然你懂计算机，你会欣赏它的。
The computer voice stress analyzer. Just explain what this is.
计算机语音压力分析仪。解释一下这是什么。
Well, the computer voice stress analyzer is an offshoot of the polygraph, or so-called lie detector. It's a recently-invented a device by law enforcement that purports to be able to tell whether somebody is lying or telling the truth based on analyzing the microtremors of their voice. The problem is the computer voice stress analyzer is a fraud. There's no evidence that it even measures anything like microtremors in the voice.
嗯，计算机语音压力分析仪是测谎仪的一个分支。这是执法部门最近发明的一种装置，据称能通过分析声音的微震动来判断某人是在撒谎还是说真话。问题是计算机语音压力分析仪是个骗局。没有任何证据表明它能测量声音中类似于微震动的东西。
And even if it did, there aren't microtremors that go off when you're lying and microtremors that go off when you're telling the truth. So the real purpose-- and police know this-- the real purpose of the computer voice stress analyzer is not to verify whether somebody is telling the truth. When they interrogated Michael Crowe, they believed he was guilty and their goal was to get a confession.
即使它能做到，也没有什么在撒谎时会触发的微震动，和在讲真话时触发的微震动。所以真正的目的——警察也知道这一点——计算机语音压力分析仪真正的目的不是核实某人是否在说真话。当他们审讯迈克尔·克罗时，他们相信他有罪，他们的目标是得到供词。
Are you sitting down?
你坐下了吗？
Yes.
是的。
Do you know who took Stephanie's life?
你知道是谁夺走了斯蒂芬妮的生命吗？
No.
不知道。
Is today Thursday?
今天是星期四吗？
Yes.
是的。
Did you take Stephanie's life?
是你夺走了斯蒂芬妮的生命吗？
No.
不是。
The real goal of the computer voice stress analyzer is to intimidate somebody who is naive or ignorant into thinking that science-- irrefutable, error-free, high-technology science has just proven that you did this and now there's no way you can deny it. It's a gimmick.
计算机语音压力分析仪真正的目标是恐吓那些天真或无知的人，让他们以为科学——那种不容置疑、不出错、高科技的科学——刚刚证明了是你做的，现在你没法抵赖了。这只是个花招。
What did you think? What were your thoughts through the whole thing?
你怎么想？你整个过程中都在想什么？
That it might be wrong.
它可能是错的。
OK, in what way?
好的，以什么方式？
That it might say I killed Stephanie.
它可能说是我杀了斯蒂芬妮。
And I can understand your feelings there, OK? You're 14 and you've been through a lot, OK? But this instrument doesn't know you, does it? Science is in our favor, OK? Technology's on our side.
我可以理解你的感受，好吗？你14岁了，经历了很多，好吗？但这仪器不了解你，对吧？科学站在我们这边，好吗？技术站在我们这边。
One of the most fascinating things about watching the videotape of this happening is how the police officer involves him in the process of working with this machine. For a long time, they sit down and they make up the questions together. Michael helps make up the questions. And he gets completely caught up in it. And then they give him the questions and the police officer leaves the room and comes back with the results and talked to him about the results and then finally reveals to him that on one of the questions, question number 12 in the little questionnaire they made up, he failed. The question, "Do you know who took Stephanie's life? Do you know who took you sister's life?"
观看这个过程发生时的录像带最引人入胜的事情之一，是警察如何让他参与到与这台机器合作的过程中。很长一段时间里，他们坐下来，一起编造问题。迈克尔帮忙编造问题。他完全投入进去了。然后他们给他问题，警察离开房间，回来后带着结果，和他谈论结果，最后向他透露，在他们一起编造的小问卷中的第12个问题上，他失败了。那个问题是：“你知道是谁夺走了斯蒂芬妮的生命吗？你知道是谁夺走了你妹妹的生命吗？”
This is common. And there's a reason why they're doing this. They know he's going to fail it. They're setting him up for failure and manipulate him and intimidate him into confessing.
这很常见。他们这样做是有原因的。他们知道他会失败。他们在为失败做铺垫，操纵并恐吓他从而让他认罪。
At some point very early on, they start lying to him about what evidence they have. They just say straight up, "We found her blood in your room." And it freaks him out.
在很早的某个时候，他们开始对他撒谎，声称拥有什么证据。他们直截了当地说：“我们在你房间里发现了她的血。”这让他吓坏了。
I'm sure you know--
我相信你知道——
What? God, I don't-- no. I don't know. I didn't do it. [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
什么？天哪，我不……不。我不知道。我没做。 [听不清]
Does that mean you can't tell me about tonight?
这是否意味着你不能告诉我关于今晚的事情？
I don't know what you're talking about.
我不知道你在说什么。
OK.
好的。
It had become one lie after another about what they have pointing to him. Is that legal?
这变成了一个又一个关于他们有什么证据指向他的谎言。那合法吗？
Yes. I think it's highly controversial in lay circles, but there's no controversy in the law. It's perfectly legal for police to lie about evidence so long as their lies don't imply promises of police or prosecutorial leniency or threats of harsher punishment. So they can make up any evidence from DNA to hairs to blood to video surveillance cameras, witnesses. This happens all the time. And it can turn their whole perspective upside down. Because once you think that that evidence must exist because the police say it exists, you come to doubt your memory. And we see this occur later in the Michael Crowe interrogation.
是的。我认为这在平民圈子里很有争议，但在法律上没有任何争议。警方在证据上撒谎是完全合法的，只要他们的谎言不涉及对警察或检方宽大处理的承诺，或对更严厉惩罚的威胁。所以他们可以捏造任何证据，从DNA到头发、血液、视频监控摄像头、目击者。这种事经常发生。它可以把他们的整个视角颠倒过来。因为一旦你认为该证据必然存在，因为警察说它存在，你就会怀疑自己的记忆。我们在后来对迈克尔·克罗的审讯中看到了这一点。
Oh, God. God. Why?
噢，天哪。天哪。为什么？
You tell me.
你告诉我。
Why are you doing this to me? If I did this, I don't remember it. I don't remember a thing.
你为什么要对我做这个？如果我做了这个，我不记得了。我不记得任何事了。
And you know what? That's [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
你知道吗？那是[听不清]。
Now, in many forced confessions, the suspect doesn't ever come to actually believe the story that they're confessing to. But they're in a situation where the police are lying to them about all this evidence they have and the person thinks, "All right, they're going to pin something on me. I might as well confess to something and get a better deal." But in Michael's case, it's really amazing. He really comes to believe that he might have done it.
现在，在许多强迫供词中，嫌疑人并没有真正相信他们所供述的故事。但他们处于一种被警察在证据上欺骗的境地，嫌疑人会想：“好吧，他们要往我身上栽赃。我不如认罪换个更好的处理。”但在迈克尔的案件中，这真的很惊人。他真的开始相信可能是他做的了。
You didn't mean for this to turn out the way it did, did you?
你不是有意让事情变成这样，对吧？
I don't even know what I did. I can't even believe myself anymore.
我甚至不知道我做了什么。我连我自己都不敢相信了。
You really didn't mean for this to turn out this way, did you?
你真的不是有意让事情变成这样的，对吧？
I don't even know what I did. Now I've been told I did this awful thing that I don't remember.
我甚至不知道我做了什么。现在我被告知我做了这件可怕的事情，而我完全不记得了。
And, in fact, if they're telling the truth, there is no other logical possibility. He must have done it.
事实上，如果他们说的是真话，就没有其他逻辑上的可能性了。一定是由于他做的。
If they were telling the truth, that's right.
如果他们说的是真话，那确实。
At one point, right around this point where they're pressing him about the notion, well, maybe he did and he blacked out, they just leave the room. They leave him alone. The camera stays on him. And he just puts his head in his arms and just sobs. He just sobs and sobs. It's heart wrenching.
在某个点，就在他们逼问他这个概念的时候，也许他确实做了但昏厥了，他们直接离开了房间。他们留他一个人。摄像机对着他。他只是把头埋在臂弯里，大声啜泣。他只是啜泣，不停地啜泣。这真是令人心碎。
[CRYING] Why? Why?
[哭泣] 为什么？为什么？
If I'm being interrogated by the police and if they're roughing me up and they're playing with what I'm thinking about myself and what I'm thinking about a crime, if I think to myself, "All right, I'm pretty sure I'm innocent here. I don't remember committing this crime. And these guys are just nuts. I'm not going to get out of here until I sign a paper." Let's say I sign the paper. I think to myself, "All right, I'm going to sign a confession." Because eventually, I'm be in front of a judge and I could just tell the judge, "Look, those guys were playing with my mind. We were in this tiny room. But here I am with you. I'm telling you this is the actual truth. I was just saying that stuff there to get out of that room." Do I have a shot?
如果我正被警察审讯，如果他们对我动粗，并在玩弄我对自己的认知，对我对犯罪的认知，如果我心想：“好吧，我很确定我是清白的。我不记得犯下这个罪行了。这些家伙完全是疯了。我不签文件就出不去。”假设我签了文件。我心想：“好吧，我签下这份供词。”因为最终，我会站在法官面前，我可以直接告诉法官：“听着，那些家伙在玩弄我的心智。我们待在那个小房间里。但我现在站在你面前。我告诉你这是真正的真相。我当时在那儿只是为了能离开那个房间。”我有机会吗？
I don't think so, usually. I've seen that happen before. People have said, "Look, I told them what they wanted to hear, but they said there was blood at the scene. I assumed once they tested my blood, I'd go home. I didn't know that I would get convicted." Oftentimes I've see this happen. Prosecutors will suggest that every aspect of the confession is false except for the admission.
我认为通常没有。我以前见过这种情况。人们会说：“听着，我告诉了他们想听的，但他们说现场有血。我以为一旦他们检测了我的血，我就会回家。我没想到会被定罪。”我经常看到这种情况发生。检察官会暗示供词的每一个方面都是假的，除了认罪那部分。
So yeah, "He said he left his fingerprints at the crime scene. It wasn't there. Yes, he said he stabbed the person. The person was shot. Yes, he said he buried the body or threw the gun in this location and it's not there. He's just trying to minimize his evil deeds and a lot of what's in the confession is false. But he said he did it and that's true. Why would somebody say they did it if they didn't do it?"
所以是的，“他说他在犯罪现场留下了指纹。那儿没发现。是的，他说他刺伤了受害者。受害者是被枪杀的。是的，他说他埋了尸体或把枪扔在了这个位置，但那儿没有。他只是想把自己的邪恶行径最小化，供词里大部分内容是假的。但他说了是他做的，那才是真的。如果不是他做的，为什么要说他做了？”
Does that usually work?
那通常有效吗？
I think it does. I think it resonates with how culturally and psychologically we think about confessions. Think about all the times when you read in the paper that somebody confessed. And most of them are true confessions. You don't stop and think, "Well, I wonder if it's a false confession or a true confession."
我认为有效。我认为这与我们在文化和心理上对供词的看法产生了共鸣。想想看，当你从报纸上读到某人认罪时有多少次。大多数都是真实的供词。你不会停下来想，“嗯，我想知道这是假供词还是真供词。”
So in the end, Michael Crowe, 14 years old, confesses to the murder of his own sister and even sort of believes that he did it. And one of the most disturbing things about watching this it is the police officers who do this, they don't seem like they're corrupt cops. Do you know? They don't seem like the guys who are out to pin a murder on an innocent kid. They seem like they actually believe they're doing their jobs and doing a good job of it and they believe he did it.
所以最后，迈克尔·克罗，14岁，承认杀害了自己的妹妹，甚至真的认为可能是自己做的。而观看这个录像最令人不安的事情之一是，这样做这些事的警察，看起来并不像是腐败警察。你知道吗？他们看起来不像那种为了把谋杀罪名栽赃给无辜孩子而做的人。他们看起来好像真的相信他们在履行职责，做得很好，而且他们相信是他做的。
I think that's absolutely right. There's no indication from watching that interrogation that they are corrupt. In fact, if they had been corrupt, they probably wouldn't have tape recorded it. And I think they genuinely believe that he's an evil person who did this. But the police, in this case, are just sloppy and they're stupid. It's not that they're corrupt or evil. They should have investigated more before they started interrogating anybody. That's one of the fundamental precepts of all police interrogation training. You never start interrogating until you've completed your investigation.
我认为绝对正确。从观察那次审讯来看，没有迹象表明他们是腐败的。事实上，如果他们腐败，他们可能就不会录音了。我认为他们确实相信他是个邪恶的人，做了这件事。但在本案中，警察只是马虎和愚蠢。并不是他们腐败或邪恶。在审讯任何人之前，他们本应该进行更多调查。那是所有警察审讯培训的基本准则之一。调查完成前，永远不要开始审讯。
I have to say, I can't figure out which I find more disturbing, the thought that some police are corrupt and forcing confessions out of people or this thought that basically, this is just the institutional way that we get a confession in our country. Do you know what I mean? "This the way we do it. We lie to them about the evidence we've got." You know what I mean? That seems, in a way, more disturbing. Or I can't even tell which is more disturbing.
我必须说，我不知道哪种让我感到更不安，是想到有些警察腐败并强迫人们认罪，还是想到这基本上是我们国家得到供词的制度化方式。你知道我什么意思吗？“这就是我们的做法。我们对他们手中的证据撒谎。”你知道我什么意思吗？这在某种意义上看起来更令人不安。或者我甚至说不出哪种更令人不安。
When I teach this subject to undergraduates, they're often split about that as well. I think myself, personally, I am more distressed by the idea of corrupt cops because I think many corrupt cops, whatever area of police work it is, have crossed a moral line and there's really a point of no return and they just get dirtier and dirtier and dirtier.
当我给本科生教这门课时，他们对这一点也往往各执己见。就我个人而言，我更对腐败警察的想法感到困扰，因为我认为许多腐败警察，无论是在哪个领域的警务工作，都跨越了道德底线，真的没有回头路了，他们只会变得越来越脏。
Does the threat of civil litigation, of people suing, as in this case with Michael Crowe's family suing the city of Escondido, as in the case that we're looking at elsewhere in today's radio show, this Roscetti case where these guys who went away for 15 years are suing the City of Chicago and the police officers. Does the fear of being sued and having to pay out millions of dollars to falsely accuse people actually cause police departments to change in any cases that you've seen?
民事诉讼的威胁，人们起诉——正如迈克尔·克罗家起诉埃斯孔迪多（Escondido）市的案件，正如我们在今天广播节目的其他地方看到的那个罗斯切蒂案件，那些入狱15年的人正在起诉芝加哥市和警官。担心被起诉并不得不向被诬告的人支付数百万美元，实际上会促使警察部门在你看过的任何案件中改变吗？
I haven't seen that cause any police departments to change. That perplexes me. It's like many of these police brutality lawsuits. The City of Los Angeles, for example, pays out millions of dollars-- millions of taxpayer dollars every year. Tens of millions to resolve civil lawsuits brought against police officers who rough suspects up. And you'd think with so much money at stake that police departments would take the initiative and try to build some protections into the system so that they would save money.
我还没见过那导致任何警察部门改变。这让我感到困惑。这就像许多警察暴力诉讼一样。例如，洛杉矶市每年支付数百万美元——数百万纳税人的钱。数千万美元用来解决针对对嫌疑人动粗的警官的民事诉讼。你本以为有这么多钱在冒风险，警察部门会采取主动，试图建立一些制度保护，这样他们就能省钱。
In Chicago, it's interesting you mention the Roscetti case. As you probably know, for several years, there's been a bill to mandate audio or video recording of interrogations in homicide cases and the police and prosecutors have resisted that and defeated that bill. It's a very simple reform, that given all the errors that the police have made, all the false confessions in Chicago, all the people walking off death row as a result of this, a simple reform like that has been resisted at every turn by the Chicago police and prosecutors. And that's highly regrettable.
在芝加哥，你提到罗斯切蒂案很有意思。如你所知，几年来，一直有一项法案要求对杀人案件进行录音或录像，但警察和检察官抵制并否决了该法案。这是一个非常简单的改革，鉴于警察所犯的所有错误，芝加哥的所有虚假供词，所有因为这个结果而走出死囚牢房的人，芝加哥警察和检察官在每一个关头都抵制了这样的简单改革。这非常令人遗憾。
Richard Leo, author of Inside the Interrogation Room. Not long ago, The Chicago Tribune looked at 400 homicide cases from across the country, cases that were overturned for the most egregious kinds of prosecutorial misconduct. Misconduct of a type that the Supreme Court has said deserves punishment. Of 400 cases, not one prosecutor received any public sanction or reprimand. Nobody lost their license. Nobody lost their job. Nobody went to prison.
理查德·利奥，《审讯室里》（Inside the Interrogation Room）作者。不久前，《芝加哥论坛报》调查了全国各地的400起杀人案件，这些案件因最恶劣的检察官不当行为而被平反。那是一种最高法院已表示值得惩罚的不当行为。在400起案件中，没有一名检察官受到任何公众制裁或谴责。没有人失去了执照。没有人丢了工作。没有人进监狱。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《这就是美国生活》由公共广播国际公司分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助商字幕]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who says that what we say about him at the end of each show has hurt his love life.
WBEZ的管理由托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责监督，他说我们在每集节目结尾对他的评价伤害了他的爱情生活。
The female associates that I had, they were trying to find that person that had been described over the radio.
我认识的那些女性朋友，她们在试图寻找那个电台上描述的那种人。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际公司。